he's the second Malaysian leader to be
charged for corruption after losing
power
mood and Yasin has pleaded not guilty to
all six charges four counts of abusing
his power to obtain 51 million dollars
in bribe's first party and two charges
of money laundering a sum of 43 million
dollars he is alleged to have committed
these offenses during his tenure as
prime minister from 2020 to 2021 and
faces up to 20 years in prison and a
fine if found guilty
this is part of
public selective position
so you have to go to court and let the
Court decide what is the real situation
and I am innocent until proven guilty by
the court
the charges relate to a government
economic stimulus program launched
during his time as prime minister
[Music]
outside Court dozens of his supporters
rallied to defend him
helping people what's wrong with this
what's wrong with this government
the charges come less than four months
after muyideen's Alliance lost a general
election
the polls were closely contested and
returned a hung Parliament it is very
heartening to see rival Anwar Ibrahim
was eventually appointed prime minister
six out of 13 states are set to hold
local elections by the middle of this
year that's again expected to be closely
fought and seen as a referendum of sorts
on the new administration's performance
supporters say the charges are an
attempt to weaken the opposition
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Kuala Lumpur